are you uh doing anything with pumpkin
season this year no no
interest no whatever
I know I was debating
but so much has changed I know that
Chris and Matt talked and Matt let Chris
know what pumpkin season may look like
what in general may be happening but
with everything going on with the
property in the house I don't anticipate
all of the kids really participating in
pumpkin season this year and sometimes I
think it's best just to
ended while you still have a good
thought a good memory about it so until
I talk to Matt I'm just not really not
sure how I feel and what I want to do
it's going to be interesting to see who
does come because they're probably going
to wonder like what is pumpkin seasoning
we're going to want to see something I
don't think it's going to be all that
much different than last year I think
it's gonna be super well attended though
yeah
time does change how you feel about
things I will not regret if this is the
last year of pumpkin season and we did
not like participate or anything like
the Glory Days when we met when it was
all of our friends yeah
at all that was 12 years ago those are
over the farm is not
like a place of joy for me anymore
[Music]